hello in this video I'll talk about n
linked like oscillation as the name
suggests glycosylation simply means
attaching a sugar tag to something now
we talk about what is this something and
what is the role of this at attaching
this sugar moiety now simply cells
attaches glycosylation tags to several
proteins and enzymes we would look in
this video and what is the role of
glycosylation and what is the advantage
of glycosylated proteins now first we
should ask where does glycosylation
takes place glycosylation starts at the
ER and several steps and modifications
happening also in the Golgi apparatus
now nline in linked glycosylation is a
kind of glycosylation or a subcategory
of glycosylation which simply means
attaching a glycol moiety glycan moiety
is basically all you saccharide a
collection of sugar molecules to the
nitrogen atom of specific aspersion
amino acid so here is the tag of
glycosylation tag that is transferred to
a protein on a specific aspersion amino
acid by the help of all use i'll
transferase and this glycosidic bond
that is formed is at the amide nitrogen
of the as perching so this is known as n
link glycosylation and this process of
oligosaccharide transfer is transferring
this glycoside attack is happening all
in the ER lumen now there are three
basic steps of this whole in linked
glycosylation first the synthesis of the
glycosylation tag that need to be
transferred to specific residues on a
protein
second the transfer of the precursor
oligosaccharide to a protein and then
further modify the tag in a several
sequential manner so we first talked
about how this tag is synthesized and
the tag is synthesized inside the ear
lumen on the ear membrane there is
Dolokhov phosphate now Dali call is a
launch in alcohol on Dolokhov phosphate
several residues of n-acetyl glucosamine
attaches then several residues of
mannose attached to that chain and it
flips inside the ER lumen and form a
backbone of this glycosylation tag later
several glucose oil transfer is
transferred glucose moieties onto this
chain and completes the chain one it
once it is completed then the tag need
to be transferred to a protein and that
is done by oligosaccharide transference
which transfer this tag to proteins by
by the help of oligosaccharides transfer
is and this is basically known as a
linked glycosylation reaction forming
the N linked glycoside bond and the last
step is processing of the oligo
saccharides and that mostly starts in
the ER but continues towards the several
levels of ecology so we know that in the
ER and also in the golgi several
different enzymes are there and these
enzymes differentially modify these
glycoside moieties in different way so
first glucose residues are chopped off
the glucose residues are very important
because by seeing the glucose residue
several chaperones which help in folding
the proper folding of these proteins can
recognize them now whenever glucose
adays chops off these glucose moieties
then the protein is now free
to move from ER to Golgi that means
cleaving of these specific sugar
moieties is important for its clearance
to move out that that in that respect we
can say specific modifications in the
endoplasmic reticulum is very important
for proper transport of the protein
second the vesicles coming from the ER
march into cyst ecology in the SIS golgi
using gold Liman oxidase one enzyme
several mannose residues are chopped off
and they are moving now to the medial
collagen in the medial golgi the key
modifications are addition of
n-acetylglucosamine residues in a
sequential fashion fashion so n acetyl
glucosamine residues are added and the
key enzyme involved in this process is n
acetyl glucosamine transferase once this
kind of modification is done
these proteins along with in along with
the modified tag is moving from medial
Golgi to trans ecology network once it
reached the trans ecology there are
other modifications such as addition of
galactose edition of n-acetylmuramic
acid or sometimes I alak acid and this
different kind of modification allowed
different differential processing or
differential sorting of these proteins
and that helps to understand that which
locations it would be delivered whether
it would be secreted or specifically
delivered to a specific organ L now this
n-linked glycosylation tag is pretty
much conserved across eukaryotes and
even our key bacterias but very rarely
in bacteria so first thing that comes in
our mind and what is the advantage of
glycosylation proteins in linked
glycosylation is helpful for protein
folding first of all you can see the end
link glycosylation helps
in overall folding of the protein in
this protein folding step it helps to
ensure that the intermediates of folding
are soluble enough such that they don't
aggravate with each other and from form
aggregation product so they help in
solubilization they also help to form a
combinatorial glyco code which could be
differentially read by several molecular
chaperones which guide the protein
folding and ensure proper folding of the
protein so in that respect in linked
glycosylation is pretty helpful now
apart from that since these these sugar
residues are very less flexible so it
can prevent the attack of several
proteases onto a specific protein in
other words it can give proteins
stability and prevent proteolytic
degradation also in case of lymphocyte
it helps in cell-cell interaction
lymphocyte in order for several
lymphocytes like neutrophil to move away
from the capillary and reaching the
tissue space require several
cytoskeletal rearrangement and slowing
down of its movement and that happens by
adhesion based interaction where several
glycosylated residues are actually
interacting with silly selectins which
are basically lectin which recognize
sugar moieties and these interaction
this annotation based interaction
actually slowed down these neutrophils
and allow them to rearrange its
cytoskeleton and squeeze through the
vascular endothelial cell layer that is
why like I said in link glycosylation is
so important in many respects now we did
talk about glycosylation we did talk
about what is the mechanism and what is
the use of it but if we talk in details
in yeast insects animal and plants the
way the proteins are glycosylated and
the specific modification that happens
is very different and also I wanted to
tell you that
not only in link like isolation there
are other type of glycosylation known as
holding declare co-citation which has
specific signaling rover I'll be talking
about Oh link like isolation in a
completely different video till now if
you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to like share
and subscribe thank you